hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played in the
aeroflot open tournament in 2004 it's a
game between Magnus Carlsen who is 13
years of age at the time and a very
strong Grand Master Sergey domatov who
is a former world champion himself in
1977 uh or rather in 1978 he won the
world junior Championship some half a
point ahead of Arthur yusufov but okay
Magnus knew that he was facing a former
world champion but domato did not know
that he was facing a future world
champion and uh yes I am recording this
as today's Magnus call since the 32nd
birthday so you guys are welcome to I
wish him uh all the best in the comments
if if you if you like and also sorry
about no videos for the past two days I
just couldn't
um I use my voice every time I I tried
to speak you know I I just started
squeaking it was really weird so it was
impossible to make a video but now my
voice is much better as you can hear and
this is a nice game that I'm going to
show for for magnus's birthday it's a
very short one but you guys will enjoy
it especially uh like I said since again
such a such a strong opponent uh maybe
if you just saw this game you would
think that it's against someone who is
not a very strong player but he had a
very very uh lucrative chess career uh
you know opponents wise uh regarding how
strong opponents he beat as he defeated
some great names like Arthur Yusuf of
Alexander believski he defeated Spielman
he defeated polkavski even defeated uh
Gary Kasparov in a team event in 1977 uh
one year prior to him winning the world
junior Championship it was a wild game
of the Queen's gamber decline he
defeated Kasparov with black because
part of sacrificed a piece for two pawns
he had two connected pass pawns on the
queen side uh but uh domatov defended
well and he was able to
utilize his advantage to grab a full
point so uh definitely a a strong player
he was crushing you know world-renowned
players before Magnus was even born but
like I said he doesn't know he's playing
against the future world champion and a
potential the the greatest of all time
so let's see how the game went Magnus
had the white pieces and he opens with
Knight to F3 he goes for directi opening
and the domato goes for Pawn to F5 going
for the sort of a Dutch reply to the
reti with D3 D6 and pawn to E4 now
Magnus strikes in the center Pawn to E5
and now Knight to C3 so no matter of
going for full development here he
doesn't want to hold anything back
Knight to the C6 we have e captures on
F5 as this was considered strongest at
the time it is still considered
strongest today he captures an F5 Bishop
captures and F5 and now Pawn to D4 this
loss of a Tempo is excused because if
Pawn captures Knight captures the bishop
on F5 will be hanging so black will have
to either move the bishop or trade and
then white gets a queen to the beautiful
D4 Square so instead we have Knight
captures on D4 Knight captures e
captures and queen captures and now okay
the bishop stays on F5 but the magnus's
queen is beautifully developed on D4 and
now Knight to F6 uh nowadays C6 is
considered to be the more precise way to
play this but okay it's not not a very
common line Knight to F6 with Bishop to
C4 and now Pawn to C6 and here Bishop to
G5 so you can see that even though black
doesn't struggle with developing his
pieces he can develop pieces freely like
it's very rare that you will see black
being able to develop both of his
Bishops uh but it's very it's not all
that easy to play and he is behind in
development and also the D6 Pawn is a
bit weak if he can play D5 he's going to
be perfectly fine and uh interestingly
there is a game that was played 10 years
after this game between Maxima Cheryl
agave and anatolivasier where H6 was
played and the maxim one that came very
nicely with the white pieces but here we
have Pawn to B5 and it is now as of move
10 the disposition has never been
reached again
uh and the Magnus has to make a choice
he goes Bishop back to B3 I will just
show for fun how G4 could be a very very
uh tricky move to face with black
because if Bishop to D7 you play Bishop
to D3 and now black has to be extremely
careful how to continue this game he has
to go for Bishop to E7 and castles uh
because if you go for C5 which kind of
is the idea you want to expand your
pawns as as much as possible Queen E3
check and there's not all that much you
can do if Queen to E7 You're Gonna Play
Bishop P4 and attack The Rook uh on on
A8 and if Queen side castles You're
Gonna Go Queen side castles and the
black's position is just terrible now uh
with the pawns so far Advanced if B4
Queen to D3 and you can already resign
this as black so a possibility uh G4
really uh goes for some uh complications
but Magnus goes for Bishop to B3 and now
we have Bishop to E7
and Bishop D7 really makes life
difficult for for Sergey uh he should
play H6 or queen to E7 check basically
he should play both of those moves as
Queen t7 check comes with a Tempo but he
goes for Bishop to E7 and now uh Magnus
just castles Queen side and there is no
good way for black to play this the
bishop here prevents castles the D6
spawn is weak you can't really move and
you know that Rook H the E1 is coming so
Queen to D7 is played uh Sergey hopes
the castle uh his King to safety Queen
side but now Rook H to E1 and even
though Castle in Queen side is possible
here look at this if Castle's Queen side
A4 and what can you do here uh you can
you can push B4 the queen covers that
square and if you capture Queen captures
and this or I mean it looks disgusting
for black
uh so instead after Rook HD1 King 38 is
played trying to get the king out of
Harm's Way trying to go for King to C7
but now Magnus just goes for Rook
captures on E7 probably the move I will
use for the thumbnail and there is no
good way to recapture if you capture
with the King uh sort of to defend the
D6 Pawn uh look at this bishop captures
an F6 G captures and Rook to E1 check
forces the king away from the pawn and
once you move the king queen captures an
F6 check and that's it you either lose
the Rook or you try to defend the Rook
by connecting the Rooks and then Rook to
E7 will cost black the queen so I have
to look after Sunny 7 Queen captures on
E7 was played and now Queen to F4 again
made possible because this weird Bishop
on F5 is undefended this comes with
Tempo now the bishop is hanging and also
the D6 Pawn is hanging so Sergey tries
to combine this with Bishop to D7 tries
to hold on to everything and now while
Magnus could just capture the pawn here
he goes for overnight the E4 absolutely
crushing a triple attack on the F6
Square also more pressure on the D6
square and of course if some of you are
new to chess you cannot capture the
Knight because after Queen captures the
Knight is pinned the Knight cannot move
so after Knight the E4 the only thing
that seems to be playable for black is
D5 which forces the Knight to move which
cuts off the Bishop from this beautiful
diagonal which closes off the D file but
that's even without all that Magnus is
still completely winning Magnus plays
Knight captures on F6 and there's no way
to recapture if G captures then Bishop
captures wins the queen so in the game
H6 was played Bishop to H4 and the G5
now it seems that Sergey will win back
his piece but not Magnus just
centralized with Queen to D4 and it was
in this position on move 19 that Sergey
domato resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here
uh problem is you're you're down a full
piece and if you try to recapture the
piece well then the game goes on but
it's just completely unplayable I would
I will just show you one fun line uh
that is possible Knight captures on D5
now attacks the queen and also the Rook
is hanging and if you play Queen to fate
to defend both now you can play Queen
captures on H4 check the Knight covers
both E7 and C7 you're gonna play King C8
now Knight to E7 check if King to C7
You're Gonna Play Queen to G3 check King
d8 and now Knight captures and C6 again
with check the bishop is pinned so King
the C8 and now Knight the E5 again
attacking the bishop twice not nothing
for black to do the only Square where
you can put the bishop seems to be the
E8 square and now you've disconnected
everything I mean look look at your back
rank this is uh something you would see
in I don't know in an eventual cast part
of a game but let's say queen G4 check
King to B8 and now just Rook to d8 with
check King to B7 and we can even finish
off with a bang Rook the D7 check Bishop
captures Queen captures with check King
to A6 and not Queen to C6 check King A5
Knight the C4 check we're gonna
sacrifice everything because this is a
made-up line big captors and C4 and now
of course a force to Checkmate in four
Queen to C7 check King B5 A4 with check
King to B for uh King to B for Queen
captures King A5 and now Queen to B5
will be Checkmate so that's basically
what would follow if Sergey continued
the game after Magnus played Queen to D4
or something similar but of course he
did not so that's why I told you uh how
how strong of a player Sergey domato was
and is okay he's retired now but uh uh I
mean he he pretty much defeated everyone
even even Kasparov but um uh yeah even
though he he did well in the tournament
and the Magnus did not Crush everyone in
that tournament he was still only 30 13
years of age but this game in 19 moves
crushing a strong Grandmaster like this
definitely uh something that I thought
we should show as this is not this is a
game that I still haven't shown on the
channel uh so yeah a brilliant game by
by the 13 year old Magnus Crossing
against such a such a very strong
Grandmaster hope you guys enjoyed that
and yeah uh feel free to wish Magnus a
very happy 32nd birthday in the comments
if you guys are into that uh as uh it's
always nice to you know congratulate
people and to wish them birthdays uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh like I said sorry about no
videos for the past two days but my
voice simply refused to cooperate but as
uh there's a lot of stuff that's
happening in the Chess World feel free
to use hashtag suggestion I will go over
your suggestions and show the the only
the the very best of games
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to wish a very
happy birthday to Peppa pepich and also
uh I would like to wish a very happy
birthday to Grisha there was and I would
like to thank ravishing reptiles YouTube
Jerry driver and born Smith for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on
everything that's happening in the Chess
World and of course your excellent
suggestions uh thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day